hey 42 here are we alone in the universe
it's a question mankind has been asking
ever since we first realized that those
twinkling points of lights in the night
sky are over stars some of which might
just be very similar to our own you'd be
forgiven for thinking this is simply one
of life's great unanswerable
who could possibly know whether or not
we're alone in the endless reaches of
space
perhaps the US government they're
definitely hiding something in area 51
and it's either aliens or the top-secret
KFC recipe for now we aren't able to say
for sure one way or the other whether
there are over advanced civilizations
out there just waiting for us to point
our telescopes at just the right spot in
the sky but science has long been trying
to figure out what are the chances that
we will ever run into our galactic
neighbors and whether they exist at all
it all started in 1961 of an American
astronomer called Frank Drake he'd
organized a meeting to discuss
humanity's pudding search for
extraterrestrial intelligence and he'd
invited everyone he knew of in the world
who was interested in the subject all 12
of them now despite the small size of
the meeting it was attended by some
seriously important people including
future Nobel Prize winner Melvin Kelvin
and a man who will go on to become one
of the most famous ever figures in the
search for extraterrestrial life Carl
Sagan but there was a problem Drake was
so busy focusing on bringing together
all these brilliant minds that he
totally forgot to come up with an agenda
for the meeting with just a few days to
spare the stressed astronomers sat down
to thrash out something so that his
illustrious friends would have something
to talk about
now when faced with this kind of
situation you or I might spend a couple
of hours coming up with fun icebreakers
or putting together pointless what's
impressive looking PowerPoint
presentations not Frank Drake he sat
down and scratched his head for a moment
then jotted down a truly unique
starter a short calculation that could
be used for estimating the number of
intelligent civilizations in the galaxy
today almost 60 years later some would
argue that the Drake Equation as it has
become known is the second most famous
formula in the world of science after
Einstein's iconic equals mc-squared
unfortunately it never garnered the same
level of popularity because well it
doesn't fit nicely on a t-shirt the aim
of the equation 2 calculates the number
of intelligent civilizations in the
galaxy is almost comically ambitious but
the equation itself is actually very
simple consisting of seven variables
multiplied together these are the
average rate of star formation in our
galaxy the fraction of those styles that
have orbiting planets the average number
of planets per star that might be
habitable the fraction of these
habitable planets that actually go on to
develop life the fraction of planets on
which life develops that go on to
develop intelligent life the fraction of
these intelligent life forms that
produce detectable signs of their
existence and finally the length of time
one of these detectable civilizations
might stick around for releasing signals
into space some of the variables in
Drake's equation we understand well
things like the average rate of star
formation in our galaxy and the fraction
of those stars that have planets some
like the likelihood of life arising on a
habitable planet or the chances of that
life developing intelligence
not so much but here's the thing our
galaxy is big let me rephrase that our
galaxy is mind-bogglingly punt wittingly
Nebo kingly astonishingly gigantic there
are four to be as many as four hundred
billion stars in our galaxy the Milky
Way that sounds like a big number
right well try this one on for size
recent studies suggest that there may be
two trillion galaxies out there possibly
more in the observable universe that
means the number of star systems out
there containing potentially habitable
planets is too larger number to fit on
this screen but why am I telling you all
this well when the numbers you're
dealing with are this ridiculously huge
doesn't really matter which values we
choose for the Drake Equation a recent
Kepler space mission concluded that
there might be as many as 40 billion
earth-sized planets orbiting sun-like
stars unthreatened wars in the Milky Way
alone 40 billion chances for life to
catch hold just in our galaxy and yes
that's 40 billion planets within their
systems habitable zone or Goldilocks
zone planets whose orbits maintain a
precisely sufficient proximity from the
host star to contain liquid water on the
surface and where there's water there's
life according to Drake himself having
played around with his
brand-spanking-new equation in that
meeting back in 1961 he and his
illustrious friends concluded that they
were probably between 1,000 and 100
million detectable civilizations in our
galaxy in our galaxy which is just one
of over two trillion our universe is
simply so huge that even if the
probability of life arising is miniscule
even if the chances of that life
developing intelligence are vanishing
there should still be hundreds of
thousands hundreds of millions of
civilizations knocking around out there
probably far more and yet we've looked
the SETI Institute has been asset for
decades and we found nothing diddly
squat
not a single peep from are insecure
magnetic neighbors now all of this takes
a rather obvious question if probability
suggests there are so many intelligent
civilizations out there busy colonizing
universe where the hell are they or
perhaps the first person to ponder on
this canonical was Italian American
physicist and Nobel Prize winner and
Rico Fermi some 10 years before Drake
jotted down his now famous equation
Fermi was in his late forties at the
time and already a world-renowned
scientist a prominent member of the
Manhattan Project he is perhaps most
famous today for being the creator of
the world's first nuclear reactor which
is why he's sometimes known as the
architect of the atomic bomb back in
1950 Fermi was eating lunch with a
couple of his physicist buddies they
were discussing the feasibility of
faster-than-light travel as you do when
you're a physicist when Fermi suddenly
blurted out but where is everybody
despite the apparent randomness of the
comment Fermi's lunch buddies knew
exactly what he was talking about aliens
Fermi had realized that the sheer scale
of our universe ought to suggest that
life even intelligent life should be
commonplace he even carried out his own
series of calculations soon after that
were similar to the Drake Equation and
he came to that very same conclusion
aliens should be everywhere
although interstellar travel is a slow
process Fermi reasoned within 10 million
years or so as if
the advanced civilization should be able
to make a pretty good go of populating a
galaxy that may sound like a long time
to was humans who have been here for
more like two hundred thousand years but
remember right here on earth
we've had species live much much longer
than that
modern crocodiles have been around for
about eighty five million years and
certain species of shark are thought to
have existed for a hundred and
seventy-five million years or more
relatively unchanged advanced species
with that kind of longevity Fermi
reasoned short have had the time to do
some serious intergalactic exploring
hence his utterance of the immortal line
but where is everybody which forms the
basis of what is today known as the
Fermi paradox the apparent contradiction
between the perceived likelihood of
other intelligent civilizations existing
in the universe and our complete lack of
evidence for them so today 70 years on
do we have an answer to Fermi's famous
question the short answer is no no we
don't the long answer well that's much
more interesting unless governments
around the world have already detected
or even made contact with alien races
and are covering and discovery up for
some reason there can only be two
possible explanations for Fermi's
paradox Eva we aren't seeing evidence of
alien civilizations because there are
non or there are just as many
intelligent species out there as we
think there should be but for one reason
or another we aren't able to detect them
let's take a look at the first option
that we haven't bumped into our
neighbors yet because we don't have any
that we are alone in the neverending
expanse of space this idea is probably
either very reassuring or extremely
depressing
depending on your appetite for living
out your Star Trek fantasies but since
our current understanding suggests that
there should be many advanced
civilizations out there there must be
something wrong with that understanding
in the first place some variable were
Eva dramatically misjudging or are
unaware of entirely suggestions for what
this variable might be are collectively
known as the great filter and for vyas
reason whatever this fingers it seems to
be preventing aliens from becoming
advanced enough to be detectable by us
humans here on earth or from detecting
and visiting laws there are many
suggestions for what the great filter
might be any one of which might hold the
key to explaining the Fermi paradox it
may simply be the case that the creation
of life from nonliving matter a process
known as abiogenesis is the great filter
it took around 1 billion years to happen
here on earth after all or maybe it's
the evolutionary leap from cells of the
simple prokaryotic variety to the
complex eukaryotic cells that make up
all higher forms of life today that took
almost 2 billion years on earth if one
of these steps is indeed the great
filter we should probably all be feeling
a little relieved right now why because
all these things have already happened
to life on Earth
meaning the great filter is already
behind humanity if this is the case
we've beaten ridiculous odds to become
perhaps the only intelligent species in
the whole universe
the alternative is rather scarier
because if a biogenesis isn't close to
but not quite impossible the great
filter whatever it may be might well be
waiting for
just around the corner and we're screwed
take a quick look back through our own
human history and you'll quickly realize
that one particular topic seems to crop
up after a lot war yes we humans have
been trying extremely hard to kill one
another since time immemorial our
ability to use tools sets us apart from
almost every other animal here on earth
but what also sets us apart is our
willingness to use those tools to murder
each other violently and often it may be
the case that intelligent civilizations
like ours are inherently
self-destructive and more likely to tear
themselves to pieces than they are to
ever colonize the Stars there is after
all a natural tension between advancing
technology and an increased ability to
self-destruct one that we see right here
on earth the atomic bomb that was
dropped on Hiroshima is thought to have
killed 135,000 people that bomb produced
an explosion of 15 kilotons just 16
years later the most powerful nuclear
weapon ever tested the Tsar Bomba which
was detonated by the Russians in a
remote area between the Barents and
caris seas produced a 50,000 kiloton
exploded 3,300 times more powerful than
Hiroshima reports suggest an alternative
design for the Tsar Bomba was
theoretically twice as powerful
to put it simply at our present level of
Technology we're much more capable of
wiping ourselves out of existence than
we are of populating the galaxy and that
seems unlikely to change in the
immediate future if other intelligent
species are similarly warlike it could
be that self-destruction is the great
filter this would not be great news for
us
the trouble is for inevitable
self-destruction to be the great filter
all intelligent civilizations amongst
potentially billions would have to share
this trait merrily wiping themselves out
just before they have a chance to spread
out a little bit it seems reasonable to
believe that if natural selection is the
primary evolutionary driver for all
species the vast majority may be
inherently warlike but all of them every
single one amongst billions that's a
little harder to believe there is of
course a second possibility here one
that is probably more likely and
definitely a lot scarier there might be
a single super predator civilization out
there that's much much more advanced in
any of the rest of us possessing
unrivaled intergalactic hige enemy and
they are systematically wiping outs to
competition before it gets a chance to
ever fight back
something to think about next time we
fire out a great big hello anyone home
into the Stars actively trying to
communicate with other civilizations
might indeed be a very very bad idea
and this is another reason we may not be
picking up signals from alien societies
perhaps they're out there but that
keeping quiet because they're far less
naive than we are and they know it isn't
safe to make their whereabouts known if
so they're probably peeking out scissors
right now from between whatever
appendages they hide behind unable to
tear their eye equivalents away from an
internment disaster that we're
idiotically calling out for a Stephen
Hawking once said if aliens visit us the
outcome would be much as when Columbus
landed in America which didn't turn out
well for the Native Americans another
theory is that over advanced
civilizations know all about us but
they're deliberately leaving us alone so
as not to disturb our natural
progression much like with Star Trek's
prime directive this is known as the
zoom hypothesis though it might more
accurately be called the nature reserve
hypothesis ever have the feeling you're
being watched yeah it's probably just an
impossibly advanced alien taking a
nostalgic trip down an evolutional
memory lane not exactly a candidate for
the great filter but very close is the
idea that we may be making like neo and
living in one gigantic matrix like
simulation this might sound crazy but
some pretty smart people for mocs of
University Professors two NASA
scientists and even Elon Musk seem to
believe there's a strong chance that
it's true if it is the case of a
civilization simply might not have been
programmed into this particular
iteration of the software although why
you would want to waste so much computer
power building a simulation of this
magnitude only to dump one measly bunch
of hell as Apes somewhere in the middle
of it is somewhat of a mystery the other
possibility
perhaps more likely than any of these
theories is that there isn't a great
filter at all and we're simply looking
at this the wrong way entirely we've
made a lot of assumptions about what
we're looking for and where we're likely
to find it we're focusing on sun-like
stars and earth-like planets because
that's where we think we might find
beings broadly similar to ourselves but
what if aliens are well much more alien
than that we're also specifically
listening out for radio signals because
they're a common form of communication
we use here on earth but there's a very
good chance of civilization far more
advanced than ours would have left radio
waves long behind them or perhaps their
technology never resembled ours in the
first place
maybe radio technology isn't even close
to being an inevitable byproduct of
intelligence dolphins are one of the
small number of species we humans class
as intelligence here on earth but as
Australian astrophysicists Charles
lineweaver points out dolphins have had
around 20 million years to build a radio
telescope and have not done so yet
nonetheless I'm confident those watery
bastards are up to something or maybe
the real reason we haven't found
intelligent life out there amongst the
stars is actually the very same reason
we're pretty sure it exists in the first
place because the universe is vast vast
in a way that we humans can't even begin
to comprehend the Milky Way is so large
that it takes light to Ralph a snappy
mover that can travel around the earth
7.5 times in a second 100,000 years to
cross it the observable universe that is
the part of the universe were able to
detect from here on earth is thought to
be a sphere with a diameter of 93
billion light years
amongst the estimated two trillion
galaxies in the universe the 100
quadrillion stars the well very large
number of planets perhaps it isn't all
that surprising
we haven't been able to find any of a
civilization just yet the she scale
involves poses serious practical
problems after all consider this if some
curious alien from Andromeda the nearest
major galaxy to ours printed his
super-powerful radio receiver directly
at earth this very second he would find
nothing nothing was an utterly silent
planet not because the radio signals
were currently pumping out aren't strong
enough to reach him although for the
most part they aren't but because
andromeda is 2.5 million light-years
away and therefore alvin the alien
wouldn't be seeing earth as it is today
at all he would be seeing our planet as
it was 2.5 million years ago back then
our species wasn't just failing to fire
off radio waves in all directions it
didn't even exist the further out into
space we go
the older the civilization must be in
order that we can detect it so unless we
happen to have some pretty close
neighbors we're only going to be able to
actually find civilizations that are
much much older than ours so as far as
the question are we alone in the
universe who knows it certainly seems
unlikely but we might just have to wait
a little while longer to prove it thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
then please consider supporting me on
patreon because it really helps me to
continue to make these videos you can
find a link in a description also you
can get your hands on a first edition
signed copy of my new book stick a flag
in it by heading on over to unbound
publishing and pre-ordering your copy
today thank you